kara is with us in North Dakota hi Kara
how are you I'm good how are you better
than I deserve
how can I help well we're pretty
desperate I went to the library and
checked out your Total Money Makeover
I've read it a couple times and I want
to start implementing that about my
husband treated he's kind of a but we to
turn things around because these are
pineapples up the wazoo okay and so if
you have financial problems and you have
a financial book that you are excited
about why is he in probably because over
the years we just we put ourselves in
the situation and I probably have done
most of it I'd screwed us up and haven't
helped budget on a regular basis
I do have bipolar so I like to spend
that time so I think he just feels that
it's something that may not work so I
think he's willing to try I would just
really like him to read this book okay
well instead of saying to him we're
screwed up we've got a big mess here I
think this book has all the answers what
you could say is what you told me
because I thought what you told me was
really compelling that you know because
of my bipolar sometimes I spend and I
have made this mess and I feel really
bad about that and it would be really a
gift to me if we could join hands and
work together to clean up this mess I
know most of it's my fault but I don't
think it's hopeless please as a gift to
me read this and consider because that's
what I heard in your voice
I didn't hear you wagging your finger at
him and him being just hopeless and
mopey I think he you know and I know I
know we've tried other things and they
haven't worked but what we're doing
right now is not working and so we need
to try something different and if we
don't do this plan we at least need to
develop a plan that the two of us come
up with together and I think if you talk
to him about that I'm amazed at the
number of times one spouse will
apologize to the other even though it is
never 100% one or the others fault and
just go I'm sorry for this mess and I
really really really want to help us
turn this around would you join hands
with me and help me do this I mean
there's very few times unless your
marriage is just in its last moments
that someone won't join hands with you
in that situation then I thought what
you said to me was compelling but we've
got a mess here you've got a man up and
fix this that one probably won't work
not in this situation anyway not with
the one you called me about I think you
can get him to do it I think you've just
got to say you know I know on a scale of
one to ten this might be a three for you
but I want you to hear me loud and clear
on a scale of 1-10 this is a twelve for
me because I helped make this mess or a
lot of this mess is mine it's a big deal
to me that we start doing something to
clean it up and if we don't do Dave's
plan that's okay we just need a plan and
so you know but but this one right here
looks good to me would you at least read
through this and look at it with me and
let's talk it through and I really think
if you come at it with that kind of a
spirit and that kind of an attitude
you're probably going to get a positive
response now the other thing is it's the
televisions off we're not standing at
the kitchen sink while he's sitting and
reading the paper this is the two of you
sitting with the kids in bed looking at
each other no electronics on no
background music no nothing just looking
in each other's eyes talking about how
important this is
this is not a drive-by conversation
while you're doing a chore you if you
want this to be important it's got to be
important and then that that
communicates also that this is a big
deal